so you break down the reasons why people
can be prone to believing something
that's not true and and you have four
categories uh where you start with the
emotional which I completely agreed with
and and believe in and you even cite
some of the same mindset of scarcity
studies uh that that affected me uh with
a suggestion that if you stress people
out um maybe other economically or
socially or in the case of the
pandemic be a isolation or uh you know
real world stress that they become prone
to uh believing certain things so so
first of all I I do want to emphasize
this um this idea that calling people
conspiracy theories is not helpful I
agree these are these are kind
intelligent wonderful people and if we
say it's them versus US it it doesn't
help us understand what's going on
and and we shouldn't we shouldn't
discount those people and we shouldn't
discount their theories in a sense that
they fulfill a real need I mean it's not
the the way I would like them to fulfill
those needs but what what happen is that
people do feel
stressed and it's not the stress of oh
my goodness my calendar is too packed
it's the stress of I don't understand
the world what is happening here and
stress gets our brain me to want to find
the story one one example I very quickly
bring in the book
is question of two tribes of
fishermen one that fishes in the lake
and one that fishes in a deep ocean and
you ask the question which one of them
has a less predictable fishing life of
course the deep ocean has you know
currents and storms and so
on which one of them has more
superstitions there ocean why because
when things are not explained we need a
story doesn't have to be true but it
needs a story so when people are
stressed they want a story but in our
case they want a story about a villain
they want to blame somebody else and
they want a story that would give them
superiority and finding a story with the
villain that is complex give them a
sense that they know something that the
rest of society doesn't
so you know we um poke fun it's people
who believe you know whatever and then
they say oh you're making fun of me I am
the one who really understand what's
going on here it's really this whole
thing with the cabal and so on and you
just don't understand right because um
and and that by the
way again it's it's a perfectly
understandable way to to plug the hole
of saying I'm stressed out and I want
the story
yeah and now now you have a story not
not a great story but but you have a you
have a story that helps you temporarily
feel better so the moment you find out
that you know it's Bill Gates in the
Illuminati or whatever you say okay I'm
I'm relaxed it's not me and I understand
the world but but that notion of being
relaxed only last a short time because
now you start saying oh my goodness what
else are they doing to us
and then you go online and you find out
worse and worse and worse things you've
started to touch on the second uh set of
factors which is cognitive um there so
there first there's an emotional appeal
to having a bad guy uh having uh an
Insider body of knowledge that you're
privy to uh and then there there's also
a cognitive appeal that's in some ways
related yeah and the cognitive appeals
are there are multiple ones one of them
is of course which news are you
watching are you watching Fox News or
NBC I mean there's a there's a
choice on which one the the second one
is our unbelievable ability uh to to
bend to bend facts to our
will you can hear one thing and
completely discounted because it doesn't
fit with your idea you can ear something
else that has three points one is in
your favor two are against and you
discount those
pay attention to that and then the last
component is our
overconfidence in our
knowledge and and there's a couple of
mechanisms there but they the one I like
the most um is is called the illusion of
explanatory depth and the way I
demonstrated it is I asked people if
they understand how a flush toilet
works you know one of those things and
people said yes and and I said great on
a scale from 1 to 7 they said I'm great
I said wonderful luckily for you I have
all the pieces of a flash toilet here
why don't you assemble it and of course
nobody can assemble it and then I come
back to them and I say okay so how much
do you understand it and people say not
so
much now if you think about it usually
when we argue with people we confront
them we we fight here's this information
here's this information you're not
hearing me there's another paper on this
and there's another fact on this and
what do you do with this and and we know
that people don't really listen they
start counter arguing even before we
finish the
sentence right and and we do the same we
don't listen to them and we start
counter argue before they finish we we
are basically in a very defensive
mode and as a consequence sometimes we
finish arguments and even though we were
exposed to new information we're even
more sure about our original opinion
because we kept on rehearsing and and
thinking of supporting evidence the the
approach based on the illusion of
explanatory depth is to say don't fight
somebody come at it from their
perspective so for example think about
the elections in the
US lots of people think that the
elections were stolen and you can try
and argue with them stolen not stolen
here's evidence here and there or you
could say okay let's not argue whether
it was stolen help me understand how
exactly it was
stolen and how do elections actually
work how do the votes get counted and if
somebody wanted to steal the election
what could they do like how how would it
actually work like let's get into the
details and it turns out that when
people get to the details like the flash
toilet they say okay you know I'm not so
sure and and part of the story of these
misbeliefs is that it's about the belief
in the outside world in something that
is ain't so but it's also taking that as
a central theme in somebody's life and
using that to look at the world as their
perspective right so so the moment we
reduce people from a 100% certainty to
95 we already are in a different world
because now they can't take it as a
central tenant in their in their
perspective and they start looking at
the world in a
maybe and that's a that's a huge step
forward so so on the cognitive side you
know there are ways to fight all of the
all of the cognitive Parts but but this
one is is the most interesting one and
one that we can actually uh start
practice hey YouTube thanks for watching
please do hit like And subscribe and hit
that Bell if you want to be notified
every time a new episode drops thank
you